foreign
modern engineering focuses on rotating
Motors to power almost any machine
is taking about 200 years for Motors to
become what they are today
and they're still loud and unnatural in
their ways
the constant noise of machines
causes problems for living beings
everywhere both in the ocean and also on
lands
humans who are constantly exposed to
noise can become stressed depressed and
even develop tinnitus
in contrast
there are no rotating Motors in nature
nature often smoothly collides swims or
Wiggles without the rattling of rigid
parts or the loud rubbing of surfaces
I believe we can and should re-haul our
approach to how we make machines instead
of using rigid or unnatural materials
what if we meet biomimetic machines
machines made of soft or living
materials they're adaptive and safe to
use in a variety of everyday tasks
can you imagine boats or submarines that
Propel themselves by moving their tails
from side to side just like fish do
so to imitate these natural movements
we have to replace rotating Motors and
fast spinning propellers with artificial
muscles
and I can tell you this this can be done
our team of researchers at MIT and eth
Zurich has started to develop less
disruptive robots by introducing a new
biomimetic way of moving through water
we created a biomatic robotic fish
her name is Sophie
she's the first demonstration of a fully
untethered soft robot that can explore
the ocean without the need for
propellers
Sophie pumps water back and forth within
her highly deformable tail
her tail movement imitates the natural
swimming motion of real fish
Sophie's natural design allows her to
closely monitor Aquatic Life
now
there's a catch
Sophie's entry hungry and loud
yes we successfully managed to build a
robot that swims like a fish but
Sophie required a motor and a pump to
properly work
now we are replacing that motor and pump
which is noisy and not desired in such a
way we're replacing it with silent
artificial muscles
these muscles are called
Hazels
they directly and efficiently convert
electrical energy into muscle
contractions
take a look at this large muscle we made
to lift and lower a leg
a stack of flexible sheets contracts and
relaxes just like the thigh muscle does
let me tell you how this works
so we take
laminated sheets
to create pouches
we have several of these pouches within
a single muscle we now take a conductive
ink and spray coat that ink onto these
pouches
and then we inject them with oil
after having done this we have a
conductive ink that acts like a flexible
electrode that squeezes these
liquid-filled pouches
when a voltage is applied
now just like muscles with real fish we
take these kind of filmed muscles
and pair them up as antagonistic Pairs
and put them into our
soft robotic fish design
with 3D print the hull
and the spine of this fish
using soft
and rigid materials
the fish now swims silently
by electrically charging the muscles
inside of the fish in an alternating
fashion from one side to the other
to improve our designs
we do not rely on tedious trial and
error fabrication
instead our software
rapidly simulates and optimizes a design
for performance before we have to build
it
our approach
creates a continuous design space that
interpolates between existing fish
designs to create new designs
our optimization then explores this
continuous design space
to come up with new and faster creatures
we have not seen before
robots one day might even be made of
living muscle cells wouldn't it be great
if such a living robot would then heal
itself just like human muscles do
I can tell you this starting from muscle
cells we can already print
Crow and stimulate muscles
we are now beginning to make these
muscles larger longer lasting and
controllable
it's the fascinating challenge to
engineer a standalone muscle without a
supporting organism that provides this
muscle with an immune system
these living muscles efficiently
converts chemical energy that comes from
nutrients into muscle contractions
living muscles can eventually become
sustainable and biodegradable machines
that decrease emissions and pollution
all while actually truly mimicking
nature
so all of this we've told you is
possible
with the knowledge that researchers and
Engineers have today
I believe we have to rethink every
machine ever invented from a holistic
perspective we have to rethink what the
machine should do and what it should not
do
I think we want machines that safely
integrate with us improve our quality of
life
all the while we respect nature and
don't pollute our world with loud noises
so let's reimagine
machines to take on forms we have never
thought of before
and discover places we have never been
to before thank you
[Applause]